えーと まあ苦しみの原因は何ですか？ということで
えーと 本当に生きることは苦しいかないか
まず考えておかないとね
で この質問は成り立たないんですよ
生きることは楽しいと
問題ないんだと 学校もとても楽しくて
勉強もとても楽しくて
親に叱られること 叱られるとものすごい快感でたまらないと
先生に馬鹿にされるとすごい快感でたまらないと思うんだったら
まあしょうがないんですよ
そうすると生きること楽しいんですよ
生きることはまあ苦しいかないかということは
この間 まあ小学生の子から質問があって
今日の朝もまた中学生の質問がといって母親に電話をかけたんでかけられたんだけど
私はまあちょっと後回しにしてくださいと
今日はまあ 今日の夜だったら返事しますと
なぜかというと 子供の質問っていうのはなかなか答えにくいんですね
難しいんです で 大人の質問だったら
まあなんのことなく すぐその場で返事出しますけどね
で で まず小学生の小学生でしたっけですね
3年生の質問から始まります
なんで私はなぜ生まれてきたんですか？と
という質問なんですね
だからまあ もしその子供が生まれてきて
まあとてもとんでもない
よかったと もう楽しくてたまらないと思ったならば
なんで私は生まれてきたんでしょうかということは考えないんですね
だから 子供に子供なりのいろいろもうトラブルがいろいろあるんですよ
で だから知りたくなるんですね
何か何のために生まれたんでしょうかね
これちょっと知っておいた方がまあ頑張れるんではないかと
それで私の答えは まあ別に子供であろうと大人であろうと同じ答え出しますけど
私の答えはやっぱり生きることには別に何の目的もないんだ
ただ 何のために生まれてきたんだと聞いても
何のためでもありませんと
それが答えですよと もし我々が生きることについて何かすごい意味があるならば
なんでそれ知らんでしょうかね
私たちは 何か目的があって生まれてきたんだったら
これが知りませんね で
皆様ご存知かどうか分かりませんだけど
私は知りません ただ生まれたんだから
こうしてジジイになるまで大きくなっただけのことなんですけど
まあ知ってる方はありがたいんですけどね
でも本当のところはそんな嘘をつくなよということを言いたいんですよ
私はこういう目的で生まれてきたんだとかね
まあいい加減には嘘ですよ
声を高くして言ったらね
みんな怯えますからね
でも その手段は私には通じません
もし目的があると言ったら
私はもう徹底的に反対疑問して
本当に知ってるかないかと
それをもう追求します
だって私が自分が生まれてきた目的を知らないのに
この人知ってるんだったら
これ大変なことだから
ですから この我々は別になんか目的があって生まれたわけじゃないということは
仏教の立場なんですよ
でお釈迦様がこの世の中をよく見て
生命の生き方を見て 自分の生き方を見て
一体全体私は何をやっているんですかと
こう考えたんですよ ですから
もし 仏教を理解したいと思うならばね
仏教の論理っていうのは
まあ残念なことにそう簡単に頭に入らないんですね
なんか分からない 要は
ですから このちょっと真剣に正直に考えると
あの なんとか理解できると思います
とにかく我々は 本当のところは生まれたんだから生きてるだけのことでしょうに
だからはっきり言えば
なんであんた生きてるんだよ
死んでないんだからなんですよ
それが皆様にできる答えなんですよ
なんでその答え出さないんですかね
仏教から言える答えは別に目的
意味がないんだよと それにはちょっと研究が必要なんですよ
それで皆様に聞けば 何のために私は生まれたんでしょうか？とかね
まあ子供は何のために生まれたんでしょうか？というんだけど
まあ大人になってくると
まあなんで生きてるんでしょうか？っていう質問はちょっと形が変わるんですよ
ですから このその時の正しい答えは
まだ死んでないんだからということなんですよ
それは 100%の正しい答えなんで
完璧な答え まだ死んでないんだから
それはかっこ悪いと言うならば
まあ古典日本語にしてね
いまだ死なずして生きてるとか
なんとか まあ言葉を変えればかっこいいでしょ
そうすると ちょっとわかりにくくしてあげないとね
なんか知ったかふりをしてくれませんだからね
ですから まあただ簡単な私が知っている日本語で言えば
まあ死んでないんだから生きてるんだと
で それぐらいでつまらないと感じないんですかね
それはつまらない質問だと
答えだと つまらないんですよ
なんか無気力な返事ではないかと
死んでないんだから生きてると
なんであんたはもうしっかり頑張りなさいよとかね
言いたくならないんですかね
もうちょっと元気を出して生きてみなさいよと
なんか暗いんではない
暗いんですよ それで人がもうちょっと元気を出して生きてみなさいと言ったら
この人はバカだから ああ
そうですね やっぱり何か方法ないんですかと
元気を出すためにと それ私に言ってみてください
いえ 別に元気出せなくても死ぬまで生きていられますよと
もう何も元気出せなくても
死ぬまで生きていられるんだから
別になんでわざわざ元気出す必要あるんですかね
もうちょっとしっかり頑張りなさい
ちょっと待ってください
別にしっかり頑張らなくたって死ぬまで生きていられますよと
私だったら言いますよ
それ嘘やと思いますか？もしものすごい力絞って
しっかり元気で踏ん張って生きて
頑張らなきゃ生きていられない
生きていられますよ どうせ死ぬまでだからね
そういうところは思考を明確にしてしなくちゃいけないんですね
それは思考を明確にする考え
パターンなんですよ すばりと答え出してみる
それには心の自由が必要なんですよ
あれやこれやとあの人
立てなくちゃいけない
この人の顔を立てなくちゃいかないとかね
自分今まで勉強したことの顔を立てなくちゃいけないと言って嘘をついたっても意味がないんですよ
誰の顔も立てる必要ないんですよ
すぐ考えて答え出せば
それは心の自由って言うんですよ
例えば 何のために生きてるんでしょうか？って
日本の古事記によると
なんとか言っちゃうと
それが嘘なんですよ 日本の古事に何書いてあったっても
聖書に何書いてあっても
それはどうでもいいんでしょうに
それは自由がないという考え方なんですね
お母さんの話によるととかね
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
ですから 何のために生きてるんでしょうか？と言ったら
まあまだ死んでないんだから
今はただ生きてるんだよと
暗いんだよ 暗いですよ
あんた元気な もう元気別にいらん
元気あってもなくても生きてられると
暗い人も明るい人も別に生きていられるんだからね
それが人生なんですよ
客観的に見ると それが全ての生命に対するこの生き方なんです
真理っていうのは この質問入れ抜きたっても同じこと
同じ答えを出すんですよ
嘘じゃないんです 聞いてみてください
それで犬と喋れませんって言ったら
これは私は知った問題ではありませんだけどね
なんとか工夫して犬と話してみてください
だからまあ 他の生命 誰を観察したっても
死ぬまでの生き方でしょうに
それである日突然 そのシステムが故障してエンストになっちゃうんです
どんなエンジンでもどんな機械でもエンストになるまでは動くんだから
別に それは皆様と同じく
ものすごい元気で明るくて生きるということで暴走したっても
その機械は あるいは暗くて
こちょこちょこちょこてゆっくりゆっくり動いてたっても
やがてエンストになるだけ
だから暴走する機械はもう早くもエンスト
エンストになるし まあそれなりにのんびりと生きている人々は
百十四歳まで生きていて
ギネス記録に載せてもらうと
そんなもんなんですよ
それで この百十四歳まで生きている人の生活リズムを見たら
まあ二日間四十八時間寝ると
それでまたもう二日間起きていると
それですごい勢いで元気で踏ん張る人々は
まあ四十で逝く人もいるし
まあまあ五十でいく人もいるし
それは様々バラバラで
だから自分の機械はどれぐらいスピードで走らせるかっていうことはね
まあどうしたっても機械の寿命があるんですよ
その時はエンストになってまあ終わっちゃいます
ですから まあそんなもんですよ
だから生きることには特別な意味がありません
というのは 仏教のお釈迦様の研究の結論出した結果なんです
そこで世の中はブッダの言葉だったら
もうとりとくも批判してますという感じで
堂々と だって脅しがないんだから
神の言葉 聖書の言葉だったら
随分丁寧にもうありがたくもう読んだりするんだけど
ブッダの話になってくると
随分漫画のレベルで読んでも読めますからね
反論出そうと思いますけどね
でもこれは一つの研究結果だから
いい加減に反論しない方がいいんです
反論してもいいんだけど
それなりに調べて反論した方がいいんですね
例えば 生きることには意味がないんだぞというと
自分でも研究してみて
お釈迦様はこうおっしゃっても
自分の研究データから見ると
やっぱり意味があるみたいよとかね
そういうふうにデータを出してほしいんですよ
それでデータ何も出さないで
さっと まあそんなことはクライヤーとか言ったってもね
まあまあ 私はあまり気に入らんとか言ったっても
それはまあそんなに知識的とは言いにくいんですね
言いづらいんですよ 言ってあげたいんですけどね
ちょっと言いづらい  生きることにはそんな大胆な目的がありませんということは無意味になっちゃいますね
生きることは無意味であると
有義ではないんです 有義ではちょっとニュアンスが変わりますね
無意味なんですよ その無意味っていうことは
ドッカというんですよ
ドゥッカという苦しいということはね
で 生きることはお釈迦様はどのように無意味かとおっしゃいましたかと考えてみると
お釈迦様は自分の研究結果はそのまま出してるんですよ
生命は生まれる それから日々年取る
それからその間で病気になったりもする
また その間でいろんな希望があったりして
それはまあほとんど叶わないんですね
で 悔しいんですね そこで希望叶って得たものでも
もう消えてしまう 別れてしまうんですよ
やっと頑張って得たものも
すぐ手放さなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
これは結構あるんですね
やっと頑張って得るものっていうのは
どうせすごい簡単に手から離れるんですよ
それから自分に付いているものはもう追い出さっても出ていかない
ついてくるっていうのは嫌なものばっかしでね
追い出しても追い出しても出ていかないものもありますね
そういうのはすべて嫌なものばっかしで
それで最後に死ぬ そのパターンはすべての生命にあります
で 結局はそれしかないと
生きることには そう言うと
なんかまあ私たちとは関係ないというふうな話がしますけど
で もっとわかりやすく世の中を考えてみると
我々の生き方っていうのは
もう人間だったらもう赤ちゃんとして生まれて
その時キャーキャー泣きながらもうなんとかなんとか大きくなる
赤ちゃんにしたっても
そんな楽っていうわけじゃないでしょうし
自分が自分の希望通りに母親が面倒見てくれるわけじゃないんですよ
自分が気に入らない時は泣くんだけど
母親はこれ何のために泣いてるかわからないでしょうに
そこでなんとかするんだけど
子供はいい そうじゃないという感じでまた泣く
またなんとかするんだけど
また子供はそれじゃないんだからまた泣く
で 泣き癖がついちゃったりして
それで母親が困ったりすると
その子はずっと泣きっぱなしで
なんか病気でもないかと
子供にとってはすごい苦しいんですよ
何か期待があって それは母親がやってくれない
例えば抱っこしてもう背中叩いてくれたっても
それが欲しくて泣いたわけじゃないんだから
バイ 倍力出して泣くんです
その時は ではおっぱいと言っておっぱい
別におっぱい飲みたくない時
おっぱい飲みたくて泣いてわけじゃないんだよと言って
もうまた倍にするんですね
泣き声は じゃあもしかすると寝た
寝た 眠くなってるから
それで寝かせようとする
これ ストレスは頂点に固まっている時は寝かせようしたっても寝られるわけでもないし
子供はもしかすると赤ちゃんが寝るつもりで泣いたわけじゃないかもしれません
それでさらに泣く もしかすると原因は自分の足につけている何かをつけちゃうでしょ
いろいろ なんかね それが嫌で
かゆくて 毛糸の靴下とかね
つけてあげてるんだからね
赤ちゃんにとってはこれすごいかゆくて嫌で我慢できない
我々から見れば なんかすごいきつい
アリがアリ塚に足を入れたような感じなんですね
引っ張ろうとするんだけど
なかなか引っ張って引っ張れない
で アリたちがバクバクと足を噛んでいる
泣くしかないんで 誰か助けてくれと
そこでもう自分の足がアリに噛まれて苦しくてたまらないとか
人が来て万歳言うと笑えるんですかね
じゃああんたは笑わせてあげますよと
さらに苦しくなるでしょうね
もしかすると赤ちゃんがこのもう足につけてるこの毛糸の何でしたっけ
靴下を嫌で泣いてるんだけど
赤ちゃんさえも知らない
これが原因やと ただすごく機嫌が悪くてイライラするだけで
それで足をいろいろ動かしながら泣いてるんであって
それで児童心理学者は足をこうやって動かして泣く時はこういうわけやと
こういうわけで言うんだけど
一つも合ってないんですよ
やがて病気になるでしょうし
ですから もう赤ちゃんにしたっても
生きることというのは
そういうふうに嫌なこといっぱいあって
苦しくて生きているんですよ
だからといって だったら赤ちゃんがはっきり言えばいいでしょ
簡単単純でしょうね 靴下外してくれと言ったらすぐ外してあげるのに
言えますかね そんなことは
単純なことですけど その生命については
これ大変な問題なんですよ
大変苦しいんですよ 言えばいいんだけどね
残念なことに言えないんですよ
では 喋るようになってくると
この苦しみはないんでしょうかね
喋るようになってくると
また別な別な別な別な問題が出てくる
喋れるようになったっても
子供は母親と喧嘩して泣くんじゃないんですかね
そうするとあれが欲しい
これが食べたいとかね
これが食べたくないとか
いろいろ言ったりしたっても
母親から見ればそういうことではいけませんということになっちゃうんですね
だから この赤ちゃんが味わう苦しみっていうのは
小さな子供にもある それで子供は家で遊んでいて
これで何でしたっけ？保育園やらいろんなところに連れて出すでしょうし
その時もそのまたそこで苦しく生きてるんですよ
では いくらか自分の話
自分で生きていられる
自分で小学生になる 小学生になったら
まあやっと人生は楽しいと
あり得るんですかね じゃないでしょうね
それで大人が勉強しろとかね
ああいう あんなものは稽古しなさい
これがやりなさいとか
隣の家の子供には負けてはいけませんとか
なんとか言うでしょうに
それに対応しようとする子供たちがものすごく苦しいんですよ
母親にまあ数字 数学勉強しなと言ったら
数学も嫌なんですけど
やらなくちゃいけない
じゃあ音楽習いなさいと
また音楽もやらなくちゃいけない
じゃあ踊りやりなさい
じゃあもう何でしたっけ
バレエやりなさいとかね
あれやれ これやれ じゃあ水泳やりなさいとかね
いろんなことをやらせると
全部そんなことやりたいんですかね
子供たちは 結局やりたくないことはさんざんやらせるんだから
赤ちゃんの時と同じく
自分にとっては生きることはそんなにもう刺激的で快感でということはないんですよ
小学生も泣いたいんですよ
中学生になってもものすごく嫌で泣いたいんですよ
なんでこんなことやらなくちゃあかんかと
私は一番悲しいのは この小学生の時
すごい頭いいのに 中学生になったらものすごい頭悪くなるんですね
だから今日朝出てきたそういう中学生の質問にしたっても
なんでこんなにも頭が悪いんですかと
ものすごいすごい頭がいい子でしたけど
小学生の時は こんなにも観察能力鈍くて
もうもうシャープな観察能力を持っていたんだけど
今は１キロぐらい もうもうもうそれぐらい
なんていうんだろう 鈍感なんです
鋭く切れる刃物が 刃物のその切れるところは広くなっちゃったらダメでしょうに
いわゆる何もわからない状態で
あれはもう学校で叩き込むものでしょう
バカになれ アホになれと
一生懸命学校で教えるんですよ
言う通りにやりなさいとか
競争ばっかりは心に叩き込んだりして
判断するは批判するは評価するは残酷ですよ
生き方は 一人一人人間には尊厳というものがありますけど
一旦中学校に行ったら
まあもう刑務所というか
もう終身刑の人々を扱っているような感じで
とにかくアメリカで刑務所で人々を扱っているところ
テレビでちらちらと見えるでしょうね
あんな扱い方なんですよ
動物としても扱ってないと
だから法律違反だからね
子供たちに悪いことはしませんだけど
やっぱり精神的に見ると点数つけられるわ
これがダメやと言われるわ
何かもう質問が子供にあっても
子供は質問したら先生は返事知らないんだから
じゃあ君はどう思いますか？君はどう思いますか？って言って
それでそうですねと それで終わっちゃうんです
すごい教育だと思っているんです
例えば 子供が自分の意見を出したって
あんたそんなこと言ったって
こういうことで違うところもあるんじゃないかとかね
先輩の人が 先生がね もうちょっと経験を持ってるんだぞっていうことさえも見せない
ですから まあ小学生になってくると人間扱いされないっていうことはね
これ楽じゃないと思いますよ
まあ子供たちはもう頭が悪いんだったら
いやいや すごい大事にされてますよと思ってますけどね
実は人間扱いはされてないんですよ
品物扱いですよ そこで元気にいること
品物扱いされたっても
で それで高校になってきたら
また同じで 大学に行ったっても
会社に入ったっても 人生っていうのはそうやってすごい巨大な苦しみがいつでもついてくるんですよ
苦しみは受験する時だけですよと
受験合格したら まあそれで苦しみが終わりということはないんですよ
で 受験 受験をして合格した途端
その苦しみは終わりますけど
それからこれというふうに別なものがついてくるんですよ
それで それその苦しみともう戦わなくちゃいけないんです
だからもうずっとついてくる
バイトしながらいろいろもう苦労しながら
もうもういい加減な四年間
大学でもう遊んでるんですけど
その時がすごく人生は不安なんですよ
無責任でいい加減で生きることも
やっと卒業したところで
じゃあ会社に入ると思ったら
それからまあもう安定して生活できるということになりますかね
そうすると大変な課題がこの環境の中で
もうかなり三十年 三十五年生きていなくちゃいけない
同じ小さな枠の中で 毎日思っただけでぞっとするんですよ
私にもその覚えがあります
自分の雇用の文書とこの契約書にサインした瞬間に
この大学の教師として
あら やられちゃったと
これで一生もう大学だったら
もう六十五までやらなくちゃあかんでしょ
仕事は六十五歳まで ああ
終わりと どこか好きなところへ
あっち行きたいなと思っても行けないと
それいくらが楽な方なんですよ
毎日大学に毎日行かなくてもいいし
外国に行くときだけ報告を出して許可を得なくちゃいかない
国の中 どこに行っても仕事をしているような感じで扱うんですよ
なのに 私はこれえらい束縛でやられちゃったなと思ったんですよ
何のことするんですかと
自分が それでじゃあ辞めますよと言っちゃうと
もう全く非常識なことだからね
これ先生たちは随分期待しているわ
みんなすごく喜んで待っているわ
あの儀式終わって帰ったんですかと言えば
先生もありますよ 憲法とかなんとかとかちゃんと守って仕事をするんだぞとか
日本ではないかもしれませんだけど
だからそれで途中でやめたと言ったら
もう今までもうもう助けてくれた
教えてくれた先生たちにはもうなんか申し訳なくなっちゃうし
どうにもならん 逃げたくても逃げられないし
先生も私はバカバカしくて
それ言いたくはないんだと言ったんです
はっきりと 言ったら まあいいえ
そういうわけにはいきませんと
それは決まりだからね
まあそうこそ気にしないでね
一応これ文章を読んでサインしてくださいということで
で もう承認も必要でしょうしね
それはえらい人々ですよ
みんな周りは でもまあ
そんなわがまま言ったっても
みんな怒らないでね まあ親切でありがたいと思うよりは
やっぱりどこかで逃げたことに逃げられないですから
やっぱりもう会社なんかの仕事
もっと大変でしょうに
だから一旦仕事を見つかった
よかった なんて幸せかと
思うのは鈍感な人で なんで幸せかじゃなくて
それに付いてくるおまけの方があまりにも大きいんですよ
おまけが決してこの楽なもんじゃないんですね
では もう退職したところで
やっと救われたですかね
退職するときでは やっと救われたわけじゃないでしょうに
その時はもうやることがなくて
つまらなくてとかね で
体の調子が悪くてとかね
では反論するかもしれません
退職してすごいバリバリ元気で最悪なんで
その時は だってすごいバリバリ元気だったらやることないでしょうに
奥さんになんか愚痴を出そうと思ったら
奥さんに出て行ってくださいと言われるし
そこで息子がもう大人になって
一人も じゃあ息子と一緒になんかお父さん
もう出てあっち行ってくださいとうるさいと必ず言われるし
相手にしてくれないんですよ
そこで では他の老人たちと一緒にと言ったら
こちらはものすごい元気だから
そちらに行ったっても
仲間にもう入れません
あちらは腰が痛い人やら
高血圧の人やら もうもう末がないと歩けない人やら
そういう人々の集まりだから
これ元気でね これまたうまくいかない
では新しい仕事を探そうと思ったら
あんた六十歳でちょっと無理ですよ
その時別に仕事をできないんだからではなくて
年上の人はバイトとして扱うと
なんかどこかでやりづらいところはありますよ
これこれダメですよとか言えないんですよ
若者に だからあれは邪魔扱いされているわけじゃないんで
時々邪魔扱いされている場合もありますけど
本当はもう言いたいことは言えなくなっちゃうんですね
向こうは先輩で経験があって
自分の父親を怒鳴るような感じになっちゃいますからね
父親だったら怒鳴ったっていいんだけど
これはもう他の人でしょうに
だからできない だからもう最悪なんですよ
人生は 退職したら元気だったら
では退職したところではものすごい病弱だったら
またそれ苦しいでしょうに
どちらにしたっても同じことなんですよ
そういうことで やがて死ぬと
それだけで終わらないんですよね
それで動物たちの生き方を見てみると
で 子育てをするでしょうね
動物も必死で命かけて子育てをする
よく頑張ることをね タコにしたっても
1ヶ月間でしたっけね
まるっきり動かないで
何も食べないで 卵に水を送るでしょうに
どれほど苦しいと考えられますかね
1ヶ月間以上休みなく
寝ることなく もうずっと
それで卵が孵化したらもう死んじゃうんです
疲れて疲れてもう何もできない
死ぬのはいいんだけど
泳げないでしょうに タコがいろいろ変なことをするでしょうにね
わかるの わからないんだけど
色を変えたり いろんなことね
そんな能力何もない それでなんとなく水の上で浮いてると瞬時に食べられちゃうんです
あっちこっちから来て
足の 1本持っていくとかね
でもそれはタコはそうなんですけど
他の動物もものすごい必死で命かけて子育てをする
子供に教育をさせる 動物もそれぞれすごいやりますよ
それも教育必要な動物はちゃんと教育させる
必要でない場合はそれは必要ないんだからね
それで年取って誰かに殺されて食べられるか死んでしまうかと
例えば虎とかライオンとか考えてください
足 2本ぐらいでも落ちたらどうなると思いますか？それで人生終わり
何もできん そこで元気なのに
体はお腹がもうちゃんと空いてるのに
食べたら消化できるのに
じっと待って飢えて死ななくちゃいけない
獲物は取れない 虎によくあることで
虎っていうのは猫だから
いつでも爪を木に研ぐでしょうに
で 虎の爪っていうのはすごい熱いでしょう
だから短剣に研いでおかないと
でもやがてあれ なんか筆のような状態になっちゃうんで
先っぽが それだけ虎死ぬんですよ
見てみると 爪の先がちょっと枝になっていて
大したことないよ 普通のカミソリでちょっと切ってあげれば
また鋭くなりますよ 私たちに頼んじゃったら
なんのことない すぐもう研いであげますよということはできますけど
単純にその頼みはしないんですね
虎も 人間だったら爪のね
あれ研ぐやつはあるでしょうね
それでちょっと研いであげれば
またもうピカピカと鋭くなってきて
それで獲物取れるのに
やっぱりそういうことで死んじゃいますよ
とにかくそうやって途中で死んだり
寿命で死んだり いろいろありますね
だから必死になって子供育てて死ぬことだけが動物の生き方でパターンであって
生まれてきた子供もちょっと大きくなったら独り立ちして
また誰かを見つけて交尾して
また必死で子供を育て
自分が年取って死ぬ で
その順番ですよ 人間も同じこと
我々の親たちがもうすごい
もう大事な大事で命だと思って私たちを育てられたんだけど
それで結局もう自分の人生よりもあなたの人生は大事ですよと思って育てて
そこで年取って死んでしまう
そこで我々から見れば
我々の人生よりは自分の子供の人生は大事ですよと言って
自分がどうなってもいい
あんたは幸せになればと
で 子供を見ているでしょうに
その子供が結婚したところでは
自分がどうなってもいいんだからといって孫のことをやったりしてて
それが意味があるんですかね
そうすると 誰の人生大事ですかね
ひ孫の人生 ひ孫の次はなんて言いますかね
やし やし やし やしゃ やしゃご
やしゃごの人生は大事ですかね
結局 やしゃごも結婚したら
じゃあ私のことはどうでもいい
君はもう幸福になりなさいと子供を育てるでしょうね
結局誰も幸福になってないでしょうに
だから 自分たちの母親から聞いてみれば
こんな世の中で唯一の宝物やと思って
自分で皆様の母親たちがね
育てたんじゃないですかね
君がこの世の中の唯一の宝物だと
本当にそうですかね 結局
我々自分一人で立ってみると
どうってことない人生なんですね
みんなに馬鹿にされる人生なんですね
誰も相手にしてくれないし
認めてくれないし 何か自分としてはすごいいいことしたっても
世界はそう それだけで終わっちゃうんですよ
なんだ それよりはすごいことはなんとか人がやってるんではないかと
すごい無責任じゃなくて無関心でしょうに
でも母親から聞けば もうこれ世界で大事な宝物やと
そういうことで 私たちも自分の子供に対して同じことを思ったりする
その子供たちのことになったら
同じことで誰も相手にしない
気にしない という人生になっちゃうんです
ですから 生老病死はドッカであると
それはすべての生命にあることなんですよ
それしかないんですよ
だから年取るために頑張ってるんですよ
みんな踏ん張って 一生懸命
元気で明るくて ポジティブ思考でとかいろいろして
こんなことやらなくても年は取りますけど
だったら遅い方がいいんじゃないですか
年取るのは この元気で頑張って
もうあの人には負けてたまりますかと思って
そんなに早く年取る必要ありますかね
ただ 人間の努力っていうのは
これスピードを速めるだけ
年取るスピード 病気になるスピード
速めるだけなんですよ
で 悲しいんですよ 時々この本当にすごい元気で明るくて頑張ってる人々は
女性の方々も男性の方々も
もうまだまだ４５か５０ぐらいとか
もうあっちこっちでがんができちゃって
あれは取りました こちらも取りましたとかね
そういう話を聞くと なんかちょっとね
悲しくはなりますよ だってこっちは何もしないで怠けているのに
まだまだ発病してないし
一生懸命頑張ってる人に限ってなんでかと
...思っても やっぱりそれ一生懸命頑張って早くしてもらったんですね
もし私の体の場合は 歳で起こる予定の病気は
すごい頑張っている方々には歳で起こると
大体心これぐらいの話はもう子供は話聞いてないんですけど
聞くと子供にはよくわかるんですよ
なんかもうバカバカらしくて
というところは まあそこら辺でお釈迦様の研究の結論として
この商と労と病 生老病死をつけちゃって
それから何でしたっけ？愛別離苦やらね
怨憎会苦 怨憎会苦とかね
好きな人と仲良くならないということはね
これ大変な苦しみんですよ
今 男二人がいるんだけど
もうちょっと年取ると
年なるとどれほど緊張するかと見てみましょう
気に入ってる誰かが女の子とかにだって
なかなか向いてこないと
行って喋ってもいいんだけど
その人に限って行って喋れなくなっちゃうんですね
他の女の子たちと仲良く遊んだりするんだけど
気に入ってる女の子のところに行ったら喋れなくなっちゃうんですね
逆にいじめたりする で
もっと逆効果でさらに嫌われちゃうとかね
男だけじゃないんですよ
女の子の話も私はもう聞いたことあるんですけどね
なんかすごい格好いい
自分にとっては格好気に入ってる男の子がいるんだけどとかね
でもこの女の子が人が頑張ってる
チャレンジしてるんだと
その子に だから大人から見れば
そんなのは恋でも愛でもなんでもないことなんですけど
で まあまだまだ子供だからね
あと年 年経ったところで本気になることなんですけど
まあどうったことないよと言いたい
そうはいかないんですよ
本人は真剣だから だから話を聞いて
ああそう 人も頑張っているんですかねとか
大変ですねということで話を終了しないと
頑張ってくださいと言ったっても怒られるし
そんなことはいいや あんた別に勉強ぐらいすれば忘れていたっても逆に怒られるし
大変で だからこの好きなものを得られないという苦しみが
もう誰でも味わっているんですよ
なんでそれを否定するんですかね
誰でも味わってますよ
好きなものは得られない
嫌な人はどうしてもついてくる
これ 子供の時はものすごくあるんですよ
男の子だったら 自分がすごく嫌で気に入らない女の子がいると
その女の子に限って もう一直線でその男を攻撃するんですよ
いろいろなんとかちょっとお菓子とか持ってきて
これはどうそうとかあげたりとかね
で 断れないし でも自分が全然気に入らんというかね
自分の好みじゃない そこでちょっとだけでも
ちょっと気に入ってる女の子たちと遊んで
こんな人はものすごく怒る
怒ると あんたに怒る権利はないぞと言えるぐらいは能力がない
別にあなたのこと好きと言ったわけじゃないんだから
誰ともそんな能力は子供にないんだから
大変ですよ だから この嫌な人と付き合わなくちゃあかんということは
子供の時からあることなんです
大人になってもあることで避けられませんよ
死ぬまで避けられません
では そこまで苦労して
我々はどんなメダルですかね
取るのは 例えば世界一長生きする人として
沖縄のどなたの名前は知りませんだけど
おば様が １１４歳まで生きているんだからといって
ギネス記録に名前を入れている
だから おばあちゃんにそれでそれで何かになるんですかね
おばあちゃんからああそうということで終わるだけのことでしょうに
そのためにギネスというある本にちょっと名前が書いてもらうために生きてきたんですかね
あまりにも割に合わないで
それだったら ですから
もう１１０歳であろうが
１２０歳であろう そこまで生きていたっても
我々もらうカップは何ですかね
人生としてメダルは何ですかね
だから客観的に虫の生き方を研究してみたっても
虫よりちょっと上の魚の生き方を研究してみたっても
鳥たちの生き方を研究してみたっても
他の４本の足を持っている動物たちの生き方を研究してみたっても
あるいは足１本もない爬虫類のヘビとかね
そういう生き方を研究してみたっても
それをあまり研究したくなければ
もう天国の神々の生き方を研究してみてください
いっぱいいるでしょうに
もう神々と喋る人々とかね
幽霊と喋る人々とかね
どういう生き方ですか？と
本当だったらね だから我々はそんなことはもうインチキな話
それを置いておいて 我々知っている
この日常生活の どんな動物の
どんな生命の生き方を見てみても
ただ生老病死で終わり
終了 それの人生であると
ですから 特別な特定な目的っていうのはないと
特定な目的がないということは
もう意味ということなんですよ
生きることに意味が意義がありではなくてなしということになるんです
それはこれでブッダの結論で
同じ結論を我々出すんだったら
そんなに鋭い質問 答え出さないこといいんですよ
いいえ まだ死んでないんだから生きているんだよと
ということになります
ですから 私はすごい苦しいんですけど
この生きることは大変ドッカであるということは証明するためには
なぜかというと この寝ている人は起こしやすい
でしょ 寝ているふりをしている人を起こしてみてください
すごい難しいんです 実際に悲しくて泣く人は慰めやすいんですよ
私たちは困らせるために演じて泣く場合ありますね
私にも皆様に経験があると思いますけど
泣かされるというんですか
相手が泣く場合は相手がないとこちらから困る
その場合 泣かされるというんですね
そうやって演技で泣かされる時は一番大変ですよ
何やってもダメだから
本当に泣かされちゃった場合は
そんな言葉はない あ ごめんねと言ったらね
それで終わる時もあります
そこで実際に生き方は苦しいなのに絶対苦しくないと思っちゃうと
もうそれ説得するのは大変難しいんです
だからこの偽善というか
偽善は良くない言葉なんですけど
この我々の思考がこの真理を知らなくて
この合成して妄想してないものを知りたいという
これ こういう機能があるんですよ
いわゆる天道思考ですけど
仏教専門用語で言えば
あの サンニャーイパーラーサというんですけどね
逆さまに見る この逆さまに見ることですからね
なかなか大変で 苦しいんです
それ それまた苦しいんですよ
私にしたっても 説得させるということは
だからブッダが真理を語ったかもしれませんよ
おっしゃったことは確実に確固たる真理かもしれませんだけど
それが知っただけでまた苦しいんですよ
誰もそんな気にしないでしょうに
教えてあげなくちゃあかんことになっちゃうし
教えた教えてあげると絶対理解してはやらんぞという立場で聞くでしょうに
それだったら放っておけばいいのに
放っておいちゃうと これは大変不親切で失礼ということになってきて
では教えてあげる いえ
聞いてやりませんと 向こうもまた立場を取るし
これはこのイタチなんとかということで
これも苦しいんですよ
だからどんな角度でどのように見ても
まあ生は空であることは脱出できません
では 今日のテーマに入ります
で 今日のテーマはこういうところから始まりますよ
そんなに苦しいなのに
なんでみんな必死で生きてるんですかね
例えば 子供たちは勉強嫌だったら学校を辞めればいいでしょうに
でも行っちゃいますよ
お母さんと喧嘩する お父さんがまああんたと喧嘩してても嫌ですよと
すぐその日でもうやめちゃえばいいでしょうに
でもなんとか頑張って続けちゃうと
会社でいくらもう侮辱されても恥かげられても
本当は死にたいほど恥かげられたりもします
でも次の日も会社に行く
なんででしょうかね 例えば
いくらお釈迦様がおっしゃったことは
素直に聞けばもうすぐ悟り開けるような教えなんです
お釈迦様の時代では 話を聞いたらほとんどもう最終悟りには瞑想しなくちゃあかんだけど
人生はすっごい並ならぬ幸福で生きるために必要な第一レベルの悟りっていうのは
もう話を聞いただけでもできます
そんなに楽なのに 聞いてなぜ聞いてくれないんでしょうかね
なぜ理解しないんですかね
なぜブッダがおっしゃってくるは
やっぱりいくら言っても間違いやと心の中で思っているんですかね
そう思ってますよ 心に聞いてみてください
やっぱり間違いと 違う立場があるんじゃないかと
これは何なのかと いわゆるこの生きることは大変やと
あなた言うこともわかりますけど
やっぱりすごい楽しみもあるんだと
そんな一方的な言い方ではないかとと思っちゃうんですよ
いわゆる人生にはいろいろ
誘惑があるんですよ この誘惑があるんだから
なかなか気がつかないんですよ
無意味であることを それで忘れちゃいます
ということは こういうことなんですよ
別に生きる目的があるわけじゃないんです
誰でも子供大人 死ぬまで生きているだけのことで
子供は子供だから遊んでいるんであって
まだまだ年取ってないんだから
学校に行ってるだけで大したことないんですよ
これはもうもう二十歳
二三 四 五 六になってくると
その年だから結婚したりするだけであって
仕事を探したりするんであって
その時その時のことをやってきているだけです
それ以上何のこともないんです
褒める必要もないんです
さすがすごいですね 君
小学生すごいですねとか
何の意味もなそうということがあるんですよ
別に年はいくつ？ 7歳なんだったら
小学生に決まっていると
決まっているでしょうに
で 男の人はあんた何歳？ 30歳35といったら仕事をしているということに決まっているんですよ
それででもちょっと変な人はこの世の中で多いんだから
で 聞かなきゃお仕事は？仕事して
ああ まあやっぱりおかしい人やと仕事してないと言ったらと
35で仕事してない ああ
そう まあ変や  それぐらいのことなんですけど
その場合は褒めることじゃなくて
ね なんでしないから私は聞きますよ
なんであんたは仕事をしないんですか？と
なぜならば そんなのは当たり前で
もう引いている線路で
別に褒めなくてももう批判しなくてもどうでもいいんですよ
もうもう二十歳になって
もう大学も卒業したらすぐなんとかもうもう就職活動しなくちゃあかんだけのことで
それやればいいし もうちゃんとした定職なかったら
まあそれぞれバイトしたってもいいですよ
私はもう 28 の男の子に聞いたら
あんた仕事何なのかといったら
まあ仕事ないよと なんだよと言ったら
その人がいろいろ定職はずっと探してるんだけど
その間はあちこちでバイトしてるの
なかなか頑張ってるんだということになるんです
その場合は だからといって褒めることできませんよ
当たり前のことをやってるんだから
定職はまだ見つかってないんだから
まあそこそこバイトして自分の生計を立てていると
そんなのは当たり前 常識で
だから  8歳の子は8歳ではなくて
もう 6歳になった子はもう 18になるまで勉強するかな
当たり前のことで そんなのはまあ
眠くなったら寝るぐらいのことでしょう
お腹がすいたらご飯を食べると
で とにかくそういうことをやっていると
なんかどこかで楽しくなってくるんですよ
例えば学校に行って勉強する時ではなくて
ゲームやっている授業中
これが楽しい そういうことになっているんですよ
結婚して子供もいるのに
他のどこかスルスルと入ってしまうね
他の人の家に それが楽しくて
この不倫することは ブッダなんかそんなこと誰が今更聞くんですかと
現代人の知識はもっといいんだよと偉そうなことを言う
調べてみれば ただあれだけ楽しいことなんですよ
ですから 人生にはいろいろ誘惑があるんですよ
いろんなものを目を開けて見ると
なんか楽しい 確かに楽しいよ
桜の花を見て気持ち悪くて吐いた人は一人もいませんだからね
それは人間であるならば
誰が見たっても楽しいんですよ
山を見たり 川を見たり
広いいろんな場所を見たりすると
これは楽しいんですよ
それさえもわかっていない日本人がいるんですよ
花を見たら どんな人間にも楽しいということは
だから ある人がブッダがこの世は甘美で
なんとかなんとか言ったんだよと
人生はすごい なんとか美しいものやと言ったんだよと
それこそブッダやと ブッダが欲に溺れてると大馬鹿者やと思ってるんです
ブッダ言った言葉じゃなくて
サンスカリット語でどこかで誰かもおかしい人が書いたものを言ってるだけで
ブッダがおっしゃったこと
パーリ語以外は大体残されてないんですけど
サンスクリット語のものはあかり
あかり 明らかに ２  ３百年後なんですけど
それが自分が分かってないことで本出したりして
みんな騙したりする ものすごい失礼な無情の言葉なんです
そんなのお釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
今私が言ったような楽しみなんですよ
富士山やらそこら辺の風景やら見て
ああ 気持ち悪い死にたいと思う人がいますかね
それは相手はたとえブッダであろうとも
見ると楽しいんですよ
自分の耳 耳元で 例えば鉄板なんか釘で打ったりとかね
のこぎりで切ったりする音よりは
バイオリンの弦を弾く音っていうのは耳障りがいいでしょうに
そんなのは決まってるんだから
どちら聞きたいんですかね
あの鉄を切るのこぎりありますね
あれで鉄板を自分の耳元でキャーキャーキーキーキーキーと切ると
あれ同じ鉄の音なんですけど
バイオリンの弦をちゃんとあれで
弾いて鉄の音を聞かせる
それはもう鉄の音なんですよ
どちらが聞きたいんですかね
それでお釈迦様が やっぱりバイオリンの音は管理されて
いろいろ音 演奏も良くて
強とか強弱のいろいろされても良くて
まあ美しい声出たら やっぱりブッダも我々と同じでというふうに
そこら辺の事実とは変わりはないんだと
と言いたいところは まあちょっと私はまあちょっと
まあどうかなと思いますね
そういうふうに単純な論理ではなくて
どう見てもこれはブッダであろうか
もう不良者であろうか
人間の耳だったら やっぱりもう鉄をのこぎりで切る音よりは
もう鉄の音を聞きたければ
バイオリンみたいな あるいはまたものすごいバカでかいベースとかあるでしょうに
そちらの弦なんか弾くと
そこでなかなか気持ちいいということなんですよ
ですから 音なんか聞くと
なかなか気持ちいいというところがあるんですよ
いろんな香りを鼻に入ると
ああ 楽しいと いろんな味を味わうと楽しいと
お腹が空いて苦しい時はご飯を食べると
ああ 美味しくて楽しいということは出てくるんですよ
だからその誘惑は確実にあります
その誘惑 欲のおかげで人生を客観的に見ることはできなくなっちゃうんです
見ないことにするんです
苦しみはなかったことにする
味わっているのに それはない
なかったことにする だから
何かを得るために一年苦労しても得た一秒のもう零点五秒ぐらいのあの時間ですごく楽しむんですよ
それで全部苦しみを忘れてしまうんです
実はそんな割に合う楽しみではないんだけど
やっぱり人間っていうのはそういう生き物なんですよ
ですから 確かにこの誘惑と言うんですよ
仏教では それはいいか悪いかということじゃないんです
そんなのは 花を見てはいけませんということになんの意味もないんですよ
花が咲いているんだったら見ませんよという人もいますけどね
私も花見に前も行ったことあるんだけど
見ないことにしたんですよ
それは特別哲学じゃないんですよ
花見ると楽しいんだけど
見えるのはゴミばっかしで
なんでゴミの山見るために行くんですか？ですから
人がない時は上野公園に行くんだぞと
その時は上野公園はすごく美しくて楽しいと
花が咲いている時だけは絶対行かんと
そういう単純な思考なんですよ
嫌なものを見たくない
綺麗なものを見たいという
綺麗なものを見ると楽しいと
酔っ払いには絡まれたくないという
もう単純なことなんです
別に哲学あるわけじゃないんですよ
なんでスマナサーラが花見に行かないんでしょうか？それはどういうわけでしょうか？とか聞いたっても
そんな難しい哲学は人生にないんですよ
ですから 花を見るなということじゃないんですよ
花が咲いてきれいだったら見るのは普通なことで
お腹が空いたらご飯を食べるのは普通なことで
どうせ食べるんだったらちょっとおいしく食べるんだと
どうせ食べるんだったら
ちょっと体に合うものを食べるんだと
そんなのは何のこともないことで
でもそれには誘惑と言うんです
なぜ誘惑と言うんでしょうかというと
そればっかりやっていて
この智慧の開発はしない
人生って何なのか 生きているということは何なのかと
だから花を見て楽しむのは別にいいんですけど
だからといってなんでバカになるんですかと
ただそれだけの答えでわかると思います
ご飯食べておいしいご飯食べなさい
だからといってバカになる必要ないんだよと
で 何があっても自分がやりたいことをやる人々いるでしょ
例えば競馬依存症になっちゃうと
必ずしもあっちこっち競馬のところに行く
負ければ負けるほどお金をかけて馬券などを買う
とことん研究する 研究足らなかったんだから負けたと
そうするとさらに研究したりして
で どんどんお金がなくなっちゃうと
とにかく家まででも売っちゃうと
なんで家売るんだ？やっぱりお金が必要だと
今度こそ勝ちますよという
その話ばっかりなんですよ
今度こそ勝たそうと思って借金もする
今度はもうあれはちょっとだけで失敗したんだからね
三ではなくて五でした
私は五書こうと思ったのに
やっぱり三にしちゃったんだよ
今度はうまくいくと その理屈でしょうに
そこで全財産もなくなっちゃって
サラ金にも手を出して
やがて殺されるか自殺するかっていう結果になるとかね
それやるなよというんですよ
ご飯食べていいんだけど
バカになるんじゃないんだと
と馬を見たらね あの馬気に入ったんだから
じゃあ 100円ぐらい出しましょうとかね
そしたらもう自分が気に入った馬が勝たなかった
あ あいつは勝てなかったねとかね
それで終わるんでしょうね
あるいは勝ったならば
やっぱり私に気に入って
私が気に入った馬がさすが頑張ったとかね
それで喜べばいいだけのことで
勝っても負けても負けてもそれ以上いくと
それがもう無知ということで
依存 依存ということで
病気ということで  治らない病気で
というところで まあポイントなんですね
だから我々は必ずしも人間には誘惑があります
目は誘惑する 耳は誘惑する
鼻は誘惑する 舌は誘惑する
体の感覚は我々を誘惑する
それでいろいろ本を読んだりすると
脳細胞も刺激を受けて誘惑する
その誘惑があるんだから
みんな生きているんです
山も登るは 海にも潜るは
何でもやる 火の中にも飛び込む
ちょっとした誘惑のために
ですから 誘惑は何をしているんですか？我々の生き方
生きてみろ 生きてみろ
死ぬんじゃないよと 長生きしろ
長生きしろと推すんですよ
ですから 苦しみの原因は渇愛なんです
タンハなんです タンハっていうのは
この誘惑というぐらいのことなんですよ
そこでこのタンハの一番目はカーマタンハ
一番目はカーマタンハ
カーマタンハというのはずいぶんわかりやすいんですよ
この見たい 聞きたいということ
五つでしょ 花が咲いてくると花を見たい
あっちこっちもう旅に出たりすると
いろんなところのある美味しい食べ物を食べたいと
踊りを見たい 音楽を聴きたいと
すごい格好家を作りたいと
そうやってこの耳 目 鼻
舌 体を刺激すること 刺激したい
刺激を受けたい その誘惑にカーマタンハと言うんです
それがあるんだから 誰一人も死にたくはないんですよ
すごくわかりやすいと思いますけど
なんで人が死にたくないんですか？というと
カーマタンハがあるんだからなんですよ
だから簡単に死にたくないと
死にたくないと言ったら
みんな嘘を言うんですよ
自殺はもう重罪だと 神様は禁止しているんだと
この自殺は重罪だということ自体嘘でしょうに
どんなわけで どんな根拠
どんな理屈で あるいろいろ宗教がありまして
この自殺はものすごい
やったらもう終わりやと
で 怯えたりするんだけど
結局は神のためには自殺してもいいとまた言うんです
また 自殺する人は絶対天国には行けないと言って
前は西洋の一番格好いい宗教の場合でも
まあ自殺しちゃうと もう教会にも入れてくれないとか言いたいよ
差別するところまでいくと
それは社会平等になってきて差別できない場合は
自分の信仰から見れば
自殺した人はもう天国には行けませんですけど
やっぱりお祈りしてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
神様は守ってあげてください
それは嘘でしょうに 本人が言ってる
だからそういう複雑で一つ嘘の生き方になってくると
哲学も思考も心の明るさも全部消えちゃいますね
ですから 単純で考えてみると
自殺はすることは罪というじゃなくて
自殺はしたくないんですよ
誰がそんな馬鹿なことやりたいんですかね
だって生きてるといろんなきれいなものを見える
友達と仲良くすることもできる
遊ぶこともできる 美味しいご飯も食べられる
音楽も聞こえる 好きなスポーツもできる
好きな趣味もできるとかね
自分せっかく作った家で気楽にいられると
なんとか何とかありますよ
誘惑は そういう誘惑はそういう風に言っちゃうと
あまりにも俗的で専門的じゃないんですよ
だから専門的に言えば
見たいものはある 聞きたいものはある
味わいたいものがあるという 5つになるんです
だから この 5つの誘惑があるんだから
誰も自殺はしたくないんですよ
罪だから自殺しない人は一人もいませんよ
それは嘘ですよ 私も自殺したいんだけど
やっぱり罪だからやめているんだよと
だからこの仏教っていうのは
この人が誰が言ったんだからではなくて
この客観的な研究データからというかね
本当の立場から語っているんです
罪だから自殺やめた人っていうのは
もうおそらくじゃなくてないと思いますよ
ただ生きていきたいんだから
自殺はしないだけのことです
なんで生きていきたいと言えば
要は誘惑があるんだからなんです
誘惑で生きている それなのになんで自殺するんですか？というと
誘惑は取り上げられる時がありますね
生きる向きでなくなっちゃうんですよ
それを自殺しちゃうんです
ですから この世の中で今まで自殺した人々は
経典に出てくるこの坊主尊者とか
そういう人々は除いて
2 3人が二人しかないんだからね
自殺する人々のことを調べてみたら
なんでかと 誘惑取り上げられているんですよ
なんで自爆テロがあるんですかね
その人たちの誘惑を取り上げられているんですよ
それですごい怒りが出てきて
自爆したり 自爆テロ活動するんです
時々誘惑を置き換えてくれる
それは精神的なマインドコントロールですけどね
今あなたは死んでも あなたにはもう優先的に特別な場所
普通の人と違って 全く VIP トリートメント
VIP で天国に喜ばれると
だから同じ宗教の人々はみんな天国に行くんだけど
やっぱり自分が VIP で天国にいたいということで
まあ体に爆弾をつけて
誰かを殺しちゃうと その時もその時
誘惑を取り上げられたよりも
馬鹿にされちゃって違う誘惑されているんです
真剣に思っていますよ
そういう人々は このテロの方々は
天国ではもう VIP で
もう自分たちの 今は隠れて隠れて洞窟の中にいろんなところで隠れているんだけど
見てみろという感じでいるんですよ
我々はもうあと 2日  3日
1ヶ月とか 2年でテロ活動をやって死にますけど
その時はもう誰よりも先に VIP で選べるんだと
ですから この自殺ということは
単純で この誘惑を取り上げられると死ぬということは
死ぬことは苦しいということなんですよ
計算で考えると 生きることは苦しいんであって
それで誘惑を足すと あれ
苦しみはマイナス数字で
誘惑はプラス数字で まあ本人が計算下手だから答えがプラスにするんですよ
それで生きることは楽しいということにする
そこである人がこの誘惑というプラス数字を取り上げられる
そうすると どんな計算下手であろうとも
イコールマイナス答えを出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから誘惑は取り上げられると
残るのは 苦しみだけ で自殺する
破壊する 破壊行動に行く
それは自分の破壊であろうとも
他人の破壊であろうとも
関係ないんです だから人生はどこかでわかったらね
生きることにそんなにしがみつかなくてもいいということはブッダの答えなのに
どうせ死ぬまでのことだから
そんなにまあこんなに真剣にならなくてもいいんだよというぐらいのことなんですけど
やっぱり人間はそれわからないんですね
とにかく誘惑欲しい 誘惑欲しい
誘惑欲しいって生きてるんだから
誘惑は取り上げられましたで言っちゃうと
ものすごく強烈に 怒ってしまう
ものすごく盛り上がりになってくる
せっかく来たのにとかね
例えば あの 遠くのところでの方々が
ここら辺で大変な美味しい食べ物を売っている店があるんだと
で まあ何か用事があって東京に来て
来る時でもこれだけ楽しみにして
その店に行くと 今日は休日やと
その店の休日なので 今日は休業
休業 で どんな気持ちになるんですかね
そんな気持ちない だから期待が多ければ多いほどショックが多いんですよ
ディズニーランドでも行こうかなとかね
まあ遠くの方々はね まあ計画を立てて立てて立てて
あれ かなりお金くうところだからね
親にもそんな遊びお金あるわけじゃないし
まあ子供一人で行って遊ぶんだったらお金は出せますけど
一人で出せるわけじゃないしね
それで家族で行かなくちゃいけない
それでまあまあ 八歳ぐらいの子供はディズニーランド楽しいんだけど
でも赤ちゃん見るのは赤ちゃんね
楽しくても何でも赤ちゃん置いていけませんだからね
それみんな家族で行くでしょうに
そういうわけで そうするとすごいお金がかかる
全部用意して やっと暇を取って行ってみたら
休園やと 特別何か何かがあって
これをやってないと言われると
そこら辺だけはちょっと入場券払って
このちょっとずつ見ることだけできると
いろんな催し物は突然止まったりしますよ
ディズニーランドでも
それだけ狙って行ったらね
えらいショックですよ
それが そんなに分かりやすいことなんですね
ですから 誘惑がありますね
生きていきたいという
いろんなことで その誘惑は取り上げられます
その時はものすごい裏切れた気持ちというか
怒りというか もうその場にその場によって我々は何か反応する
あの人のせいで私の仕事がなくなったよと思ったら
その人を殺すかもしれません
母のせいで私の生きていきたかった道ができなかったと思ったら
母を恨むかもしれません
国のせいで不幸になったと言ったら
もう何か反逆行為行動するかもしれません
それはその場にその場によって決められます
自分のあほらしさで誘惑が取り上げられちゃったと行っちゃうと
自分に返ってくる 例えば気に入っている相手がいて
自分がいろいろ工夫したんだけど
それが失敗でもうダメになっちゃったと
なんて自分がバカな人やと
もう生きてちゃって意味がないと
これ自分に返ってくるんですよ
だから誘惑を取り上げられた
このそのその現象によって
人の怒りは爆発します
ですから 怒りは当然破壊ですね
これは自分を破壊するか
他を破壊するか 他のものを破壊するか
どちらかわからない この何ですかね
この山のせいでなんとか思って山を壊しちゃうでしょうに
だから物を破壊する人
生命を破壊する あるいは自分を破壊すると
どちらかかする それも誘惑の結果
それで破壊するときどうしますかね
簡単じゃないんで それも計画立てないと
破壊プログラムは 例えば年足すプログラムだったら
その人は年間生きていないと
また生きる目的が達するんですよ
自殺したい人 人はそれでいろいろ計画を立てたり
手紙を書いたり なんで自殺すればいいのに
遺書を書いたり 靴を揃えておいたりとか
例えば あれがもうバカバカしくて
で ビルから落ちて死ぬんだけど
ビルに行って それで靴を外だからです
なんだあれはね いかに無知でアホでねということでしょうに
そういうことに皆様方は手を合わせて鼻を上げてるんだから
みんな自殺を応援していますよ
私言うことを言ってみてください
公でみんなやめろ そんなことは
死んだって馬鹿にされるんだから
完全な馬鹿でしょうに
何回何回もテレビで見たんですよ
ビルから落ちてきちんと靴そろってとかね
遺書まで書いたりとかね
なんで遺書を書くんですかね
やっぱり何か期待あるんですよ
例えばいじめられただからといって
誰か誰かの名前を書いて
やっぱり自分で何か計画期待あるんですよ
死んでからそういうそういう人々にはもう何とかしてくれという
遺書を書くこと自体で自殺はしたくなかったというね
ということになるんです
ですから 遺書を書いたり
自殺の方法を考えたり
場所を探検に行ったりとか
いろんなことで生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
自殺するまで どうせ誰でも死ぬまでの生き方だからね
ですから 結局破壊意志が入ると
また生きるための目的が達してしまって
だからこの大量殺人やら破壊ことやらするこのテロやら
そういう人々 とにかく自分が必死で生きることは必死なんです
楽しいんだからじゃないんですよ
洞窟に隠れたり 山に隠れたり
あらゆる所で隠れたり隠れたりして
パスポートを偽装したり
もうあんていることをしてもう大変ですよ
普通の人の生き方よりはもう何千倍も苦しいんです
苦しくてとにかく生きていると
例えば飛行機に乗ってテロ爆破するんだったら
それは簡単じゃないんだから
操縦士の免許まで取らなくちゃあかんだから
それまた簡単なわけじゃないでしょうに
でもずっとあの破壊意志で生きてますよ
ですから それも一つの誘惑なんです
自殺も誘惑なんですよ
結局は 自殺願望も だから馬鹿で
そんなに誘惑してたら楽しく遊べばいいのに
だからまあ それは自殺するのも馬鹿馬鹿らしいんですけど
やっぱり本人にとってはそんな単純なことじゃないんだからね
ですから この破壊自殺する意志
他殺したがる意志 破壊したがる意志
それは誘惑を取り上げられると
それで誘惑は取り上げられました
もう怒ったぞと言って生きるんです
ですから それも誘惑というんです
お釈迦様は ヴィパッサナー
うん で まあそういう誘惑があるんだから
我々は生きることはドゥッカであるとは理解しなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで この 花を見て楽しむためにも
毎日美味しいご飯を食べて
ごちそうを食べて 子供たちと仲良く遊んで
気楽に生きるために 楽しむためにも
ものすごい一つ大事なことがあるんですよ
欠かせないことがあるんですよ
家族で楽しくするためにも
いい仕事をして たくさん金を儲けて
それで好きなところに住んで
ブランドの服なんか買って生活するためにも
外車でも買ったりして
楽しい生き方でしょ それは悪くはないんだけど
ものすごい大事な条件が一つあります
それがなくなると全部終わり
何一つもできない どれなんですか？と何かと思いますか
そう それは生きて生きて生きていなきゃ何もできませんだからね
ですから 我々にとっては何よりも大事なことは生きること
生きることになっているんです
生きていなきゃ美味しいご飯も食べられないし
旅にも出られないし 結婚もできないし
子供と遊ぶこともできなくなっちゃうし
もう何一つも楽しみがなくなっちゃうんです
人と喧嘩することもできなくなっちゃうんですね
敵がいるんだと 敵にあらゆる邪魔をしなくちゃあかんと
足を引っ張らなくちゃあかんと
そういう計画を立てて実行するために自分が生きていないと
ですから この誘惑からついてくる
ものすごいもう捨てがたい
徹底的に頑固で心に定着している誘惑は生存欲なんですね
ですから それは中心的だから真ん中に書くんです
真ん中に書いたのは これ
仏教の誘惑のリストを順番はその順番です
カーマタンナー ババタンナー
イバタンナー 生きていなきゃ全部終わり
何もできない そこでいとも簡単にみんな生きていきたい
生きていきたいと思っていますよ
なぜと聞いてるの？わからない
ちょっと見ればわかることなんですけど
ちょっと考えれば でもそれを認めたくないんで
お前ご飯食うために生きてるんではないかと言っちゃうと怒るんですよ
もうもうプライド傷ついたと
だからみんなわからないことになってるんですよ
小さな子供なんか見てください
ただ食うことだけでしょうに
それほとんど欲はそれだけ
だから母親の仕事はいつも何か食べさせる
何か食べさせる 何か食べさせる
ある時々私はそれを観察してみると
私にある日なんかダブっちゃってしまったんですよ
この人間の母親が子供にいろいろもうもうやっているんですけど
動物の母親と全く同じくジャブっちゃったんですよ
動物の母親たちも一生懸命餌を運べ
餌を運べ 餌を運ぶと では
人間の母親は子供に何をやっているんですかね
一生懸命何か食べさせる
何か食べさせる それで子供に言ったら
あんた食べることだけの人生
食べるために生きてるんではなく？と言ったら
それを怒っちゃいますね
そんな本当のこと言ってなんで怒るんですかね
だからもうそうやって
このただ誘惑を得るために生きてますよ
みんな まあ子供は食べることだけで納得いくかもしれません
大人になってくるとまた誘惑が増えますしね
そのためには生きているだけのことになってしまう
ですから このそのために死んだらあかんということになるんですよ
だからこの自殺にすべて自殺してはいけないということは
日本のインテリの方々はたまにすごい説法というか
説教というか 講演とかするときもありますけど
そういう方々の話の中で
まあまあ死んだら全部終わりでしょうと
だから死ぬなよという結論を出すんですよ
だからそれは私から見れば答えではないんですけど
言ってるのはこういうバワタンハなんですね
生きているとあらゆる誘惑があるんだよと
死んじゃうとすべての誘惑が終わりますよと
だから死ぬなよと でもこのインテリの方々はわからないのは
そんなのは自殺する人も知ってることなんですよ
実は死にたくはないんだと
それは自殺する人は知ってますよ
なのに なんで死ぬんですか？ということに答えを出さなければいけない
それは扱わないんですね
そうすると仕事なくなっちゃいますし
返事出しちゃえば終わりだからね
例えば政治改革なんかしちゃったらもう仕事終わるでしょ
だから永久的にしないで
で まあ自分の仕事は 続ける
だから約束っていうのは果たすもんじゃないんですよ
果たしたら終わり 神様もそうでしょ
たくさん約束してますけど
一つも果たしたことはない
脅しもありますけどね
脅しも果たしてないんですよ
他の約束も果たしてないし
もうもう最終的に審判してみんなもう処分するぞとか
まだまだないんですけど
やっぱり約束っていうのは果たすもんじゃないんですよ
果たしちゃうと仕事終わりますからね
うん まあとにかく まあそれは冗談で言いましたけど
普通のインテリの方々にはそこら辺は見えないかもしれません
やっぱり生きていれば全部終わりますよということは
別に誰でも知ってることで
でもなんでそれなのに人が自殺するんでしょうかというと
それは生きていられなかったからなんですよ
生きていられ っていうことは正しくはない
生きてはいられるんですよ
誘惑がないんですよ 生きようとすると誰かにいじめられると
本当は学校に行きたいんですよ
行ったらいじめると 先生ぐらいでも自分の問題を見て
なんとか親切に何かしてほしいんですけど
先生も無視すると自分のこと
だから誘惑はない 楽しみはない
だから誘惑を奪われるとすごい苦しみになるんです
なぜならば 生きることは苦しいんですよ
それに誘惑で何かペンキを塗ってかっこよく見せる
もう壁紙みたいなもんですよ
壁紙が破っても剥かれちゃうと
部屋っていうのはえらい気持ち悪いんですよ
だから壁の中身は何で作っても豪華な豪華な壁紙貼れば貼るほど
もうすごい贅沢 贅沢な部屋ですよと言うんですよ
それは普通の数字な数学なんです
本当は今このタイル貼ってます
これ石ですよ 本物の でも本当に豪華というならば
この台そのものが石であった方が
ものすごい豪華ですよ
でもそれはね だから普通のセメントでコンクリートで床を作って
薄い薄い石 石の機械で貼っておく
そうすると石屋という感じがする
壁紙の場合も同じです
単純なベニヤ板で壁を作って
豪華な布で作って模様が出ている壁紙を貼っちゃうと
どう？見てみてください
時々金で金糸でいろいろ模様し
模様を作っている壁紙もあります
皆様の家ではないかもしれませんだけど
まあまあ それ壁紙のお金で家一つ買えるかもしれませんだけど
でもそれで豪華ということになりますけどね
もし壁そのものをちゃんとしたものができているんだったら
本当に豪華なんですよ
例えば 壁そのものがちゃんとこうやって磨いて
きれいな石で畳で作っていると
日本で言えば国会と都庁ぐらいのことかな
豪華  それはまあ それで私たちはこの生きるということは苦しみ
苦し目の上に 誘惑というちゃんとした壁紙を
ちゃんとした絨毯を敷いて
まあいい雰囲気にする
それでその絨毯を誰かに取り上げられると
壁紙は全部誰かが抜け抜けてしまっちゃうと外してしまっちゃうと
どうなるんですかね 自分の部屋はもうダメやと
もう住めないんだと ということになる
今まですごく気持ちよく自分の部屋でいたのに
ああ もう嫌だ 同じ部屋ですけど
こちらはもう住めない
不潔だ 寝られませんと
ということで その部屋を使えなくなる
それで人間も人間の誘惑を取り上げられると
もう生きることは苦しいんだ
大変だ もう生きる意味がないんだ
もう死ぬぞと言って死んじゃう
だから そういうふうな死に方を見ると
もう何か証拠です 何か証明されますかというと
生きることは本来苦であるということなんです
限りなき苦しみがありますけど
だから我々の数学では
限りなき苦しみあったっても
ほんのちょっとのプラス的な誘惑入れちゃうとプラス結果出すんですよ
これは計算違うんじゃないかというのは仏教なんですよ
例えば マイナス4の苦しみに
プラス5を足せば1になりますけどね
私は数学じゃないんだから
ちょっと知ってる人は書いてお節介したってもいいんですけど
マイナス5ぐらい苦しみがあるところで
その人にはマイナス3ぐらいかな
忘れちゃった マイナス3ぐらいの苦しみがある人にとっては
まあ例えば マイプラス4ぐらいの楽しみがあると
そうするとプラス1の楽しみが残っちゃいますよ
それは正しい数学 でも我々には無限のマイナスの苦しみがありますよ
それにプラス1ぐらいの誘惑あったって
もうプラスだ プラスだと決めちゃう
これがこれにケチつけてるところだけ仏教なんです
あんた方の数学って変だよと
そこは仏教の世界なんです
だから 例えば徹夜して子供がもう寝ないで寝ないで泣いたっても
ものすごくお母さんが疲れて疲れて死にそうに苦しんでやっても
あの赤ちゃんがそのちょっとちょっとニコッと笑っちゃうと
いきなり楽しくなってしまっちゃうんです
こんなまあ 二 三秒笑ってくれたと
今までの得た苦しみで引いてみなさい
これ引かない 全部チャラにする
それが普通の生き方なんです
ですから  その数学もちょっと正したいっていうところは仏教の立場なんですね
もうちょっと見てくださいと
まあとにかく苦しみの原因というのは
とにかく生きてみろ 生きてみろ
生きてみろという この嘘
誘惑なんですよ 生きた方が何かいいことはある
何かある だけど確かにあるんじゃないっていう
それは誰もわからないんですよ
何かがあるはず 何かがあるはずということで誘惑を負っている
だから そうやって誘惑論を入れて考えたっても
生きることは無意味で
何の目的もないんです
ただの誘惑 そこで 私たちの日常の生き方っていうのは
この欲愛か存在欲か ヴィパッサナーというの破壊欲か
その順番で回転で生きているんです
その 3つが衝動ですよ
生きるエネルギーなんですよ
このみんな元気で明るく活発でいたっても
結局この三つを言ってるんですよ
負けず嫌いで元気で もうただの怒りなんですけど
悔しくてとかね あるいは単なる欲かもしれません
で 病気になって倒れたっても
存在欲で じゃあ頑張ってくださいと
しっかりと あの病気になって死にかけている人にはね
まあちょっと例えばあんた瞑想でもしたらすぐたちまち治りますよと
ったらやってやるんです
その時は 何でもやります
その時 例えば病気になっても
まあなる見込みない人にとっては耳元でね
これはもう誰にも言ってない秘密ですけど
親指様 私を助けてくださいと
朝と昼と夜  31000回 1000
回 3000回唱えてください
二日目で治りますよと言うと治りませんだけど
言うとそれやるんですよ
やります やります 確実に
ですから その時はどんな衝動ですかね
存在欲 生きていきたい
死にたくはないということで頑張るんですよ
で こちら この質問もいろいろありますけど
一つあるのは このまあ例えば地震が起きると
存在欲が機能してみんな必死で避難すると
はぁ やっともう命だけは助かった
財産がなくなっても 家が壊れちゃっても
やっぱり助かったと喜びを感じると
そこで避難所でいると
まあうまく物事はうまくいかないと
で 避難生活が長くなってくると
まあまた薄になっちゃうと
それどういうことでしょうかというと
存在欲がもううまくいったんだけど
避難所でいると一番目のカーマタンハが普通の五欲の方が取り上げられちゃうんですよ
家族はないとかね 気持ちよくお風呂に入らないとかね
他の他の人々と一緒に寝泊まりしなくちゃいけないと
今まで家族だけで寝たのに
全部あっちこっちぼちぼちちょっとした仕切りで
で 自分で好きな料理を作って食べられないと
まあ避難所の状況によりますけど
時々この支給する食べ物を食べなくちゃいけないでしょうしね
そうやってそのことを長くなると
やっぱりこの一番目の五欲を取り上げられてるんですよ
それで薄になったり 自殺したりすると
だから人間っていうのは
まあそのサイクルで このカーマタンハかババタンハかヴィバワタンハか
まあどちらかどちらかどちらか
もうあの表に出て行動する
でも 3本も一緒の糸に糸みたいな感じでつなげています
一般の方々にわかるぐらいの苦しみの原因っていうのは
まあそれで以上終わりですけどね
まだもうちょっとランク上の話もありますけどね
まあこれはまあ喋った
喋るよりは喋らない方がいいと思いますけど
はい いいですか  えっと
私はこの大を見た時に
あの と その今長老がお話しになったこととよく結びつかないんですね
で 今言われたことで 四諦の教えのことはよく分かったので
それはそれで満足してるんですけれども
あの なんていうか 苦しみの原因はなんですか？ということで
えーと もっとそうすると
なんていうか 僕は誤解してるんだと思うんですけど
僕は誤解してるんだと思うんですけれども
まあ人生は苦だっていうことはもう大前提みたいなもので
それのそれを それの原因がこの割愛っていうことではなくて
苦しみが苦しみっていうものを割愛というもので
その見せなくしているという風に今
だと思うんですね で そうすると
僕なりに解釈しちゃうと
苦しみの原因はなんだ？と言われると
その無知だっていうか
無明っていうことなのかなと
苦しみっていうものは
もう人生は苦しみなんだから
そのことがわからないということが
むしろ苦しみの原因の答えはそういうことのようで
割愛というのは その苦しみというものをその理解できないっていうか
わからなくしているものが割愛だというふうに聞こえた
あの聞いたんですけど
なんか私が変な風に理解してるのか
いえ 別にそれでいいと思いますけど
苦しみの原因 それだと苦しみの原因は渇愛だっていうふうに私にはつながらないんです
だから苦しみ 渇愛は生き生き続ける衝動でしょ？生き続けるということは苦しみ続けることでしょうに
衝動さえなければね 苦しまない
だから衝動を消せと だから
だから  とりあえずは あの生きてる限りは苦しみなわけですよね
うん そのことを知っていれば
では 衝動がないと生きていられますかね
ご飯食べる気はまるっきりないとかね
体動かす気さえもないとかね
家から一歩も出る気持ちもないとか
やりたい何かしたいという衝動がないと
ですね うん ちょっともうちょっとよく考えてみる必要はあると思うんですけど
あの そう簡単ですよ だからこれはこの一番初めに人間はこのね
わかるところね 一般的に話す場合
お釈迦様は五人の比丘たちにはこういうことを出してますけど
この答えはね 専門的に分析する場合は
渇愛とアヴィッジャと渇愛とアヴィッジャ
その 2つで まあ輪廻は苦しみが続きますよと
アヴィッジャがなくなったら悟りが開けてわかってしまう
で それで終わりだと だからアヴィッジャ
タンハ アヴィッジャ タンハで言ってます
アヴィッジャ タンハはもう最初から教えているはこの教え方次第ですよ
どんなアプローチで言うかということは
今おっしゃっているのは
このアヴィッジャのことはどうしますか？というふうな感じのことで
だから無明とタンハはまあ仲良く頑張っているんです
ブッダは 2つも原因にしているんです
無明は原因で 渇愛はだまし屋でということにはしてないんです
だまし屋というのは無明もだまし屋なんですよ
だからそんなに うん  もう少し頭が
そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
もう単純ですよ  両方とも
原因では両方とも原因
ドッカ隠すんだったら両方とも隠している
そうすると原因っていうのの私の理解がちょっとこれがあるから
あの なんていうか 原因っていうものは
苦しみが生まれてくるものの原因というふうな理解なんですね
だからね だからこちらでは普通にちょっと難しいところは
苦しみの原因も本当は苦しみでしょうし
だからそこら辺でちょっと普通の論理とちょっと難しいところが出てくるんです
それがあるから苦しみが生まれてくるっていうもんじゃないんですよね
うん 例えば苦しみと全く関係ない別な原因があって
苦しみをぼんぼん生み出すと
例えば鉄砲がいて 鉄砲がぼんぼん弾を
撃ちまくると 弾と鉄砲はというのは随分違うでしょうに
鉄砲当たったら人が死んじゃうし
弾当たったら人が死んじゃうし
鉄砲って何のこともない
据えに使うこともできるし
ということで そうやって原因と結果っていうのはまるっきり違うものって取ってるわけじゃないんです
渇愛も一応苦しみそのものなんですよ
アヴィッジャーそのものも結局苦しみそのものなんですね
海と波と女みたいなもんですよ
波が暴れるとかなり海は危険でしょうし
波がないんだからといって海ってのは安定したとこでもないしね
同じものはいろいろ変化する
うん そんなにそこら辺難しくはない
一応仏教ではドッカの原因といえば
といえばアヴィッジャー出すか渇愛出すか
両方出すかどちらかなんですね
でもこれを今 今日の話は仏教では昔からも決まってるというか
お釈迦様が決めた まあもう形式で
だから純粋にお釈迦様が教えた方法でいくのは
私のやり方 仕事だから
無明アヴィッジャーは一応導入しない
今日は導入しないんだけど
ちらちらとアヴィッジャーにも参考にしたはずなんです
うん  十二因縁で考えると
最初無明があって いろいろあって接する
触があって 執着があって
渇愛があって 苦がある
だからここから見れば全部まあ苦の原因といいますか
そうそう 大元は無明と
その十二因縁から見ます
うん そう考えてもいい
そうですね それも正しいですよ
だから説明の仕方っていうのはいくらでもあるということで
そこで我々に理解しやすい説明で
だから仏教は勉強している人々には
こちらの方の説明も こちらの方の説明もいいんだけど
全く知らない人々にとってはこういうアプローチが
これは現代的で いくらか西洋的なアプローチなんですよ
これはもうすごい存在論的で
生きていることは何でしょうかっていうところで考え
こういう方が正しい説明なんです
こういう衝動が密あるんじゃないかと
だから無明に無明をアヴィッジャーに立ち触ってほしいんだから
私は生きることに何の目的もないんだけど
誘惑にもう騙されちゃって
とにかく生きていきたいんだと思うと
だからそれだけでも まあバカではないかということが入ってるんですよ
何か何か他の方はないかと
なんで考えないんですかと
誘惑したくてしたくて生きていたっても取り上げられるんだからね
そっちいつでも だからここじゃで取りたいと向こうは取り上げるという
いつでもそうでしょ こちらは金が欲しいんだけど
あげる側があげないあげないこと
その戦いですよ ずっと
だからこの誘惑は欲しいんだけど
なかなか出てこないから戦わなくちゃいけない
そんな道じゃなくて 何か別な方ないかと
例えば誘惑は全部取り上げられちゃうとえらい苦しみが出てきて
もう普通 このブッダいうドッカではなくて
本物のもう生きていられなくなるほど
本当の我々知ってる苦しみが出てくる
それで人を殺すことにもなって
自分を殺すことにもなるし
ではいっぱい好み通りに誘惑が全部あるといいことそれでもないでしょうに
何でも期待通りにうまくいっちゃうと
ものすごい またかえって危険
かえって面白くなくなっちゃうんですよ
で またいろいろトラブル起きますしね
とにかく だから何か他の道がないんでしょうかと
その他の道を探さないところが無明の概念出す出発点なんですね
そこで他の道でお釈迦様は八正道を紹介するでしょうに
涅槃を説明するという場合は
この衝動を潰してみなさいと
この 3つのね カーマタンナー
バワタンナー バウタンナー
で アヴィッジャーがあるんだからタンナーがあります
この 2つは一緒です いつでもアヴィッジャー消せばタンナーが消えちゃう
タンナー消す踏ん張っちゃうとアヴィッジャーも消えてしまう
だからどちら取ったってもいいっていうことだと
どちらの説明もその通りで正しいんです
別に問題がないんです
でも 今日のアプローチも勉強してほしいんです
今日のアプローチは ...もっと一般的で
みんなに共感しやすいというか
アヴィッチャー出しちゃうと
それ何？ってことになります
でも有悪論はそうは言えないと思います
まあ当然難しいことは難しいかもしれませんだけど
ちょっとしっかく教えると
それぐらいはわかりますよ
そういう教え方ではなくて
これもお釈迦様のね 説法だからね
はい えっと 余が貪瞋痴っていますよね
その貪瞋痴と この何かカーマタンハとマーマタンハとヴィバヴァタンハっていうのは
なんか対応してる気がしたんですけど
それは全く全然違う  そのまた専門的な説明になりますから
私は専門だけは避けたいんですよ
これは専門になってくると
こちらにはもうえらい簡単単純でも
もうもう寝ていても説明答えられますけどね
で なんとなく当てはめることはできそうな気がするんですね
カーマタンハにはむさぼりを当てはめて
怒りにはイババタンナーを当てはめて
無智にババタンナーを当てはめると
そういう風に似ているという風に取っているのは別にいいと思いますけど
でも決定しない方がいいんですね
また まあ別に問題ないと思いますけど
別に 私にはやっぱりこの仏典でそう言ってないと証拠全くないんだから
大胆にそれで決定ということだけはちょっと言えないんです
でも考えてみれば まあそれはその論理も成り立ちます
間違っているとは言えませんね
それではちょっとまたさっき聞いちゃうんですけど
渇愛っていうのは苦しいから起こるっていう
ん？ 渇 苦しみのほうが渇愛の原因じゃないかっていう
その なんかなんでそういう質問
さっきの質問が出てきたのかなと思ったら
そういうところがあるように
喉が渇いた時には苦しいんですよね
だからこう 水が欲しい
水が欲しいっていう風になるんじゃないかな
うん  だから渇愛の原因が苦しみじゃないかなっていう風に
渇愛の原因 渇愛の原因は苦しみやと
うん だから同じことでしょう
生きることは苦しいんだから
渇愛が生まれると  まあだから別に分けないで同じことなんだなっていう風に言ったとしてもいいですかね
うん だから総合効果というか
だからまあ まあ見方によりますけど
別に 同じことやといえば同じことなんですよ
例えば目があることも苦しいし
目があると見たくなっちゃうし
見ることもかえって方は逆に苦しいしね
だから渇愛自体も苦しいんですよ
だからこの前も言ったんだからね
もう結局は原因というものも苦しみですよ
鉄砲と鉄砲から撃つ弾みたいな差がないんです
同じものです 渇愛自体も楽しいわけじゃないんです
そうすると ではいっそどちらが何が楽しいか？という疑問が出てきますよ
生きることは苦しい それで渇愛が出てくる
誘惑があるとかね それ自体も苦しいしね
それでだからどこで楽しみがあるかと
それで無明は慣れで耐えますけどもね
そういう方向で考えると
すごく難しくなって複雑になります
で 私らにとっては その思考ではとても簡単に考えちゃいますけど
一応できるだけ避けたいんですよ
そんなに難しくしちゃうとダメです
とにかく難しくする必要はないんです
仏教は 誰にでもわかるように単純にしてあげないと
だからって仏教のレベルを下げるわけじゃないんです
レベルは高いままで置いといて
すごい単純なやり方で理解してもらう
一旦理解したら全部わかります
だから私はチャートやらリストやらもう全部避ける
どうしてももう 避けて避けて避けて
ただの日常茶飯事の悪口やら
いろいろ人を馬鹿にするやら
そういう普通の日常の話からこの論理を紹介しようかと
うん そういうことなんですが
はい 先生のお話終わっていかなと
質問も出てますので  いえ
まあどちらでもいいんです
それはまあ  話をしてしまったら
今の質問する方々は 一応そこら辺をちゃんと理解しているんだから
話は脱線にはなりませんですけど
他の方々には別な時間がないと
いや 一旦ちょっと休憩しましょう
ではちょっと  少しちょっと飲んで
ブッダが教えるこの だからお釈迦様は何を教えたいんでしょうか？というね
やっぱりお釈迦様がこの幸福を説いたいんですよ
ブッダが決して空論者
空論 空論者ではありません
で よくこのこの間なんか見てないんだけど
この知ってるつもりっていう番組があったそうで
私はその時忙しかったんだからね
それは英字新聞で宣伝だけ読んだんですよ
宣伝読んでも1日が機嫌が悪くて
そこら辺に関係ない人に当たったんですけどね
で そちらでこのまあ英字新聞でね
知ってるつもりっていう番組で
このブッダについて ブッダっていうのは
まあインドで仏教という宗教を作った人やと
人ですと書いて He was obsessed with the problem of suffering という
読んだだけで これどこかのまあ十五六じゃなくて
二十三 五 六歳ぐらいのバカなバカな外国人が書いたでしょうと
アメリカ人ですからね
英語書くの何もわからない
もう日本の小学生ぐらいだな
ものすごく怒っちゃったんですよ
その一行に ちょっと勉強した人っていうのは
そういう言葉使いは使いませんし
皆様にはそんなもうこの微妙な内容はもう関係ないと思いますけどね Obsessed
というのは この まあ何でしょうかね
何かに取り憑かれて 依存になって
いわゆるオタクになったような
ブッダが苦しみについて取り憑かれて
そこのオタクになって
そんなようなニュアンスなんですよ
それはちょっとだけ大学ででもそれなりの研究をしたならば
そういう品のない英語を使わないはずなんですよ
たった一つの単語なんですよ
あなた方のテレビ番組もどちらかというとそんな態度ですから
そういうもん軽々くね
まあ見ちゃうし そんなね
そこら辺のね もうマスコミの人々にわかるものじゃないんです
ブッダの教えは ブッダは決してこのもう苦しいや
苦しいや 苦しいやとかね
そんなキャーキャーと泣く教えを教えてるわけじゃないんですよ
あー苦しい あー大変だ
嫌だ 嫌だとか バカバカらしい
そんなことは で 逆に あ
なんて素晴らしいだ この人生はなんて素晴らしいものですか
なんとか楽しい なんでもものすごい楽しいやとかね
神様ありがとう 感謝しますとかね
あれ見ると私は 私はこれ冗談なんですけど
そういう人の話を聞くと
私 私にできるならば あなたの人間としての
まあ何て言いますか あれを取り消したいんだと
今日からは人間ではありませんと
そういう法律ないんだから困ったもんだなと
と思ったり それは冗談で思っちゃいますけど
ただバカみたい これなんで神様感謝します
感謝します こんな楽しい世界とかね
言うこと自体残酷で失礼でしょうに
なぜならば この世の中でどれほど人が苦しんで
食べられ 食べるものがなくて
行くところが場所がなくて苦しんでいるんですかね
だからもう感謝 感謝 感謝で生きていることでも全く無知であー苦しい
苦しい 苦しい 苦しいとね
生きることっていうのは
そんなものは智慧のある人の道じゃないんですよ
だからブッダが苦しい
苦しいとかね 泣き叫んだわけじゃないんですよ
堂々と勇気を出して幸福の扉を開けますよと
そんなことを言ったんですよ
アパールタテーサンアムタッサドワラン
私はもういわゆる聞きたい人々に
彼らにとってはアムタッサドワラン
虫の扉をもう開きましたと
いわゆる幸福の扉を イエスオータワントパムンチャスサッダン
聞きたい人々はもう硬くならないで
もう信頼しなさいと ですから
このブッダは決して苦論者でも悲観論者でもありません
俗世間でいう楽観主義者でもありません
どちらでもあんまりにもおかしいんですよ
物事わかってないんだから
そういうことを言うんであって
ブッダは実論者で事実を語るのみであって
だからといって方法を持たないと無意味な話になりますよ
ですから 勇気の話をする
事実であろうとも 別に知ったんだからどうったことないでしょうに
例えばエイズなんかにかかったらもう治療は不可能ですよと
なぜですか？と エイズウイルスのはこういう風に構造ができているんだから
これは治療できる それ知ったんだから
何になるんですかね だから知っただけで何にもなりません
だから何か知ったならば
何かの方法論も出さなくちゃいけない
そういうことで 実際のことを語って方法論も出してます
ですから お釈迦様は幸福を語っているんですよ
だからブッダは私は幸福の人であると
スコブッダナンウッパと
ブッダ現れること自体が幸福であると
ブッダは不幸の種でも何でもないんですよ
だから部屋中 ブッダの仏画とかにかかっておいた方がいいんですよ
たった唯一人間に幸福を語った人だから
たった唯一人間の幸福を願っていた人だから
たった唯一 我々は騙されているんだと勘違いしているんだと
悪徳商人にね で 教えてくれた人だから
このカラクリから騙しから抜けられる方法を教えたたった一人の人だから
いまだに誰にでも間違っているよと言えることはできなかった
唯一の教えだから 仏像は壊す人はいくらでもいるんだけど
ブッダの教えは壊れませんし
ですから ブッダはすごいことを教えていますし
それもまた誰にでもわかるしね
本当にすごく心が子供ぐらいのレベルに
このややこしい傲慢もね
強情もなくしちゃって
すごく明るく楽しく単純に聞いてみると
ああ なるほど そういうことかっていうことはね
わかるし 今日私は本当は紹介しようといって
いろいろ尼さんたちの経典は一応持ってはきたんだけど
ちょっと時間はないんですけどね
極普通の女の人々が出家して
しっかりと修行して マーラな誘惑が隠されたってもね
まあすごいするが するすごい鋭い言葉言ったりとかね
するところはありますけど
まあとにかくこの まあこの ２行目
最後から見るとね まあ苦しみなく幸福に生きていられるのでしょうか？というね
で 苦しみがなく幸福に生きていられる方法は 2つあります
2つあります で 一つは
どうせ生きることは苦しみんだったら
生きてい なんで生きる？何て言うんですかね
このその生きるということをちょっとなんとかして違う方向に変える
それは言葉がないんですよ
生きることは苦しみであったら
じゃあ生きていなかったらいいでしょうと言ったっても
それは単なる反対の言葉で
ですから生きることは苦しみであるのから
やっぱり生きるというふうに言えない
ある状況があるんじゃないかなと
それは解脱なんですけど
だから解脱といって このシステムから脱出すると
それは究極的な幸福であって
それはお釈迦様が提案するすごいレベル高いのを幸福であって
それは一つ もう一つはこれから喋ります
で 人が悟らなきゃ苦しめというのは
まあそうなるんですけど
それはちょっと失礼な言い方で
では 治療完治するまで何か助けてあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
ですから この完全な治療方法はありますけど
この完全な治療法で結果はまあちょっと時間がかかるんだと
だからってそこまで苦しめ苦しめなくちゃいかないかというと
そうじゃない すぐあなたは楽にしてあげますと
例えばすごい病気な人が来たらね
大丈夫 大丈夫 すぐ楽にしてあげます
ほんの 2 3 分で でもそれで病気治ったわけじゃないんですよと
それからきちんと治療しなさいと
それは 2 3年かかるかもしれませんと
でも その間はずっとあなたは楽にはしてあげるんだと
ですから 治療を受けようとして
その日からその人は病気で苦しまないんですよ
楽にしてくれたんだから
医者が それでまあ楽で
どんどんどんどん正しい治療法を受けて
心機一にすればよろしいということで
ですから 幸福になる方法は 2つあります
一つはもう完全な治療を受けて
まあこの 3つの誘惑を心から綺麗になくすということ
これはやっぱり 30 分では無理ですね
これかなり精神的な問題だから
生きていきたいという気持ちを捨てな捨てなさいと言ったっても
わけもわからないでしょうね
生きて生きる気持ちを捨てたらどうなるんでしょうかと
わからないでしょ 例えばこれが生きるエネルギーですよ
この誘惑っていうものは
欲望を楽しむ 食べ物などなどを楽しむ
仕事を楽しむ 給料は楽しむとかね
家族を楽しむということは生きるやりがいなんですよ
それで敵なんか嫌な人がいたら
その人の悪口を言ったり
その人の足を引っ張ることなんか計画立てたり
それでやりがいなんですよ
我々は幸福になるよりは悪いことする方がいくらでももう頑張りますよ
ちょっと 10 分待てと待てと言ったら待てないでしょうに
イライラして 誰かの噂
あなたね この人はこの 2時からもう明日の 10時までもう写真撮れますよと
あの人を連れてくる可能性あります
と言ったら  24時間じゃなく
48時間でも待ってますよ
その時は そんなもんでしょ
人間っていうのは この噂の写真撮れたと
それでああ お布団に入りたいとかね
お風呂に入りたいとかね
ちょっと美味しいものを食べたい
何でもないんですよ ハンバーガー食べたり
あるいはもうなんとかもうパンやら菓子パンを食べたり
コーヒー飲んだりして２日でもます
怒り 怒り 憎しみでえらい頑張っちゃいますよ
では いいことに１日頑張ってください
言ってみてください もうイライライライラできない
だからとにかく人間に悪いことでもいいことでも
それで刺激的で生きてますよ
それはやめなさいと言ったら考えられますかね
怒り 憎しみがないと生きていられないという人はいくらでもいますから
競争がなくなったら終わりやと
もう生きていられませんという人
いくらでもいますよ だからそんなの理解さえもできないんですよ
これ治しちゃったらどうやって生きていればいいかと
だからそれは矛盾です
だから生きることは苦しいと言ってるんではないかと
こっちが言いたいんだけど
簡単にはこのアホ 生きることは苦しいと言ってるんだよと
どうやって生きていればいいかというと
だったら生きていなさいと
別に何もする必要ないんだと
こっち来るなよと あんたこっち来たのは生きること苦しいんだからと言って来たでしょうにと
だから原因を知っただけですよと
それでまた逆にそれだったらどうやって生きてますかとまた聞くんでしょうね
だから人間というのはそんなもんでしょと
わかりにくいんですよ
だから我々には想像できない
違うと言ったっても このあの世の話ではない
超越した話でも天国の話でもなくて
ちょっとこれは知識の問題でね
知識でちょっと理解できない
この涅槃の状況なんですけどね
まあそれはですから 一応その滅をなくせば幸福なんですが
そこまでどう生きていられるかと
それに私の答えはこういうこと
それもお釈迦様の答えから現代訳しています
例えば 子供の仕事は遊ぶことを
それを適当に遊べばいいという
そんな大した大胆なことではありません
小学生になったら学校に行って勉強することで
だからそういうその時その時の
仕事はごく普通の当たり前のことで
難しいわけでもないしね
それはその時その時やっておけばそれだけですよ
サボったりする必要もないんだと
それで人間というのはすぐサボっちゃう
勉強する時は勉強しない
で 大変な結果になる 苦しみがものすごく増える
勉強する時 勉強しなかったら
仕事をするべき時 仕事をしなかったら
後であんた方は泣くんだよとお釈迦様は言ってるんです
何でしたっけ？なんとか鳥が鳥が出しちゃってね
乾季で湖の水が全部なくなっちゃって
もう魚がいない そこでサギというかしらさぎというか
その鳥がその枯れた湖で泣いてるんだと
この場を失った人々は
場というか この機会をね
だから そのやるとき やるべき時はその仕事をするんですよ
すごい単純ですよ 料理の時間だ
じゃあ料理作ると 部屋が汚れた
じゃあ掃除機かけると
ちょっと体が汚れたそうで
あ じゃあお風呂にしましょうと
ですから ものすごく人生っていうのは
まあまあすごい単純に見なきゃ
何の不思議もないんだ
何の哲学もないんだと
何の目的もないんだと
そういう人々を見ると
本当にもうこちらまで楽しくなるんですよ
なんであんたご飯食べる？ちょっとお腹が減った
その単純さの素晴らしさっていうのは並みじゃないんですよ
例えば 何でご飯食べる時
そちらで花を一つ花瓶
だってそれ綺麗でしょ？綺麗でしょ？それで終わる
その人生はすごい幸福なんですよ
もし なんであんたお腹が空いてご飯食べるんだったら
そちらに花瓶で花入れておいたんですか？と
言ったら それはですね
ギリシア時代で ローマ時代で
メソポタミアででも 人間が食卓に花瓶を入れておいたとかね
これはメソポタミアの何とかの花
花のその形を真似て この花にしたりしたらもう不幸ですよ
だからそんなで人生は幸福にならない
で なんであんたご飯食べるところでこの花花瓶一つ置いてるの？だって綺麗でしょ？それで終わるんですよ
だからメソポタミアの話する人も綺麗だからやってるんですよ
気に入ってるんだからやってるんです
だからそんなに単純なのに
幸福で生きてれば生きていられない
これを誰のせいですかね
だから授業を受ける時はもう授業を聞けばいいでしょうに
授業中は遊んだり寝たりする
それで一生泣くことになる
それで先生たちはあなたの将来のことを考えて勉強しなさい
これが不幸の道なんですよ
不幸の教えなんですよ
将来なんかどうでもいいんですよ
授業に行ったらもう聞いた方が楽だから
話は でなきゃ 授業にも参加して何も聞いてないって
あんたバカでしょうと
そういうことになるでしょうに
だから授業に行くと真剣真面目に聞いてみたら
なんであんたそんなに真剣に聞く？だって
でなきゃ損するんだからと
どうせこちらに 1時間半いるんだからね
聞いてやる そうと全部
そういう単純な生き方だったら
完璧な生き方が成り立つのですよ
万円札持って買い物はするんだけど
1万円以上は絶対買いませんと
そこで自分で気に入っている何か部品がありまして
やっぱりこれはもう 1万8000円だと
買いたいな でも 1万円に決めちゃったんだけど
まあでも買いたいと そういう生き方
苦しいんですよ やっぱり今日だけ約束破りますとか
今日約束破る人がもう永久的にそんなことやっちゃいますからね
そういうのは苦しい いくら気に入ったっての今日買わんだからねと言って帰ればいいんだからね
死に物に文句言って あんた気に入ったんだからと買うと思ったら
おうちが 1万8000円でしょうに
私は 1万円のものしか買いませんと
だからもうそんなもんで
ものすごく幸福に だから後で悔しくないんですよ
後で考えたって だから
この 1 秒  1 秒でやる仕事っていうのは
ものすごく単純ですよ
その 1 秒の仕事  1 秒の仕事っていうのは
どんな人間にも完璧にできるはずなんです
1 秒の仕事 これは医者であろうか
大工さんであろうか もう他の人であろうが関係なく
自分の仕事は簡単単純ですよ
ですから その 1 秒の 1 秒の仕事
その今やらなくてはいけないこと
それだけやってくださいと
今やってはいけないことをやっちゃうと
もうとんでもないことになる
例えば お手洗いに行ってやるべきことをこちらでやったらとんでもないことになるでしょうに
で なんでみんなそんなことをやるんですかね？やってはいけないことはやってはいけない場所でやると
それで不幸でしょうに
お釈迦様おっしゃってるのはそんなことなんですよ
やってはいけないことはやってはいけない場所でやるなよと
それに膨大な経典をお話しすることになっちゃったんですよ
我々が悪いんですよ 単純でなかったんだから
頭あまりにも悪いんだから
だから頭が鋭い 鋭いっていうのは
ものすごい頭が単純ということなんですよ
ものすごく複雑でガチャガチャだったら鋭くないんです
だから あれこれとものすごいことを教えても
でも あの なんですか 小悪魔さとか日本語で言ったらもう悪いことをするなかれ
それぐらいの話ですよ
まとめて言えば それで理解してもらえばすべて終わるのに
そうはうまくいかないね
聞いてくれない それで humanであろうか
もう膨大なアビダルマであろうか
宇宙論まで語る それでもわからないという
ですから この幸福に生きるということは
もうあの誘惑に負けることじゃないんですよ
誘惑を探すことじゃないんですよ
今の一秒でやるべきことはやる
やってはいけないことは絶対やらないと
それはもうだらくします
それから 3番目 サボりはしませんと
今やることは後回しにすると
もう不幸ですよ それから価値を捨てる
例えば 仕事っていうのは尊いものだと
学問ほど素晴らしいものはこの世の中にないんだよと
子供たちを気持ちよく勉強しなさいと
いや 誰もやってくれないと思いますよ
価値を入れると重いんですよ
勉強で遊べないんですよ
だから物に価値を入れるではないんです
絶対入れてはいけません
例えば 自分が買ってきた花瓶は
これはもう大変な 有名な誰かの作家のものだから
ここでももうもう 500万円で買いましたよと
いで こちらでもう花を立てているんですよとか
そういうふうな価値を入れると生きていられなくなるんですよ
本当に自分が 500万円ぐらいの喜びがあるんだったらいいんですよ
例えばこの花瓶を見ると
ああ 楽しいな きれいな
この綺麗さは 500円ぐらいでも価値ありますよというならばいいんですけど
そうでもないでしょ ガラクタでしょうに
誰が作ったっても それは作家の名前で
ピカソの絵みたいに 誰が見たっても気持ち悪いのに
ピカソが有名だから 何千万でも払っちゃうと
自分 自分にとって気持ち悪いんだったら
それは気持ち悪い それで終わり
相手がたとえピカソであろうとも
ですから 価値入れることで生きていられなくなります
それで我々は まあ仕事であろうが何であろうが
今やらなくちゃいけないことをやる
なんでやってますかと
いえ これは尊いことだからやってますと言っちゃうと不幸な人なんです
なんであんたは今日ものすごい朝早く起きて仕事に出かけたんですかと
だって仕事っていうのは大変な素晴らしい尊いことであって
だから会社にはやっぱり分前でも１時間前でも行っておかないと
これは大変な天道様にお天道様に申し訳ございませんとかね
もう不幸中不幸で そういう人に触れた空気さえも吸わない方がいいんです
それでなんであんたそんなに朝早く仕事で？だって座っていけるのにと
あんた知ってますか？５分遅れるともう万年ですよ
それで十分です それで十分です
なんで会社にちょっとあんたもいつでも分先に行ってるんだよと
ああ 私は分先に行って
コーヒー一つ飲んで もうタバコでも一服吸って
ちょっと机のところをいろいろ整理して
まあ我が家のところに一応なじむんだと
それで仕事の時間になってくると
もうもう温かくなって
もう仕事バリバリできるんだそうと
気持ちよくね だからだってそれだけのことやと
嫌で嫌で仕事したくないやと
途中でコーヒー一杯飲もうと行ったところで
やってる仕事を忘れちゃってね
次にどこまででしたっけ？と
だからそんなことなく
落ち着いて楽しく仕事できるんだから早く行くんだ
単純なこと理由があるならば
その人は本当に幸福なんですよ
でも なんであんた子供を抱っこしてるの？こいつは抱けと言ってるんだから抱きましたと
その人が幸福で あっ これは我が子で
命のほどほど大事に守らなくちゃいけないんだと
まあそいつは不幸で だからなんであんた子供を抱っこ
抱っこしてますか？こいつは抱きなさいと
泣いちゃうんだから抱っこしてあげましたと
だから この幸福がそういうすごい単純なところに存在するんです
なぜならば 人生には意味がないんだからなんですよ
だから 瞬間瞬間のことに意味はつけない
意味はつけないと楽に生きていられる
だからまあ それが生き方なんです
それがすっごい気持ちよく幸福に生きられる
でも その人は誘惑を追っていかないんですよ
別に誘惑がカーマタンナよ
食べたいんだから仕事をするんだとかね
豪華な料理を食べたいんだから
外国旅行したいんだから頑張りますよとか
徹夜して それは不幸ですよ
だから今の生き方をブッダが教えるような生き方では
こういう密は使ってないんです
生きていきたいんだからとかね
私の名前 将来まで子供はもう名前を続けるんだから子供を育てるんだとかね
とんでもない話なんですよ
自分のお墓参り お墓を何ですか
守ってくれるんではないかとかね
想像できない不幸な話なんですよ
そんなのはどうでもいいんですよ
もうなんであんた子供生まれてきたんだからね
こいつらはね もう一応可愛いしね
面倒見ているんだと 子供に何が来て別に何も期待してないんだと
ただ可愛いんだから面倒見るんやと
学校に行ってるんだから全部用意してあげてるんだと
勉強しないでふざけてるんだから
学校 子供ってのは勉強するだからぶん殴っちゃったとかね
そういう単純なやり方で生きていると
ものすごい限りない楽しみ
幸福が現れてきます